so hello everybody my name is mikhail
svetkin
and i'm software engineer at cisco and
today we are going to talk about cube
property
yep okay
something wrong with the slides they
don't wanna
go next yeah okay now it works
yeah so the cube property is a new class
which is going to bring
us a qml property binding into c plus
plus
this class is going to be part of q6 and
it's going to be
one of the major features of the new
release before we go into deep dive and
q property
first of all we need to refresh our
knowledge about qml properties
what does it do what does it provide to
us and what we can do with that
after that we can take a look how we are
going to have the same features in c
plus plus
and how it will affect the q framework
itself
so chemical property binding just a
fast refreshment that qml is a
declarative language designed to
describe the user interface of your
program
and the javascript is used as a script
language inside of the qml
qml property binding was one of the
success story of the qt
qml itself it allows to write a ui very
very easier
and more readable way so i hope we will
get the same things in c
plus plus so let's take a look at the
simple example
here we have two rectangles uh one
inside another one
and one of them has a fixed geometry
white and height two hundred and the
second one has only white
and the height is kind of referral to
the root element
so if i run the example and
and just try to resize the object you
will see that
wherever i resize the white rectangle
the
blue one is also resized his height is
calculated
it it depends on the white one so
that's basically what is the qml
property binding is
uh
the view the qml property binding is
designed to find wide protective
property to another one
and in that particular example the
height of the blue rectangle depends on
the
height of the root rectangle
so so that's what what property bank
does
it's bind one property to another one or
to the multiple one
so in that as i said in that example the
rectangle height depends on the root
height and every time root height
changes value
it will immediately change the rectangle
um
blue rectangle height as well so
in that in the terms of the qml the root
height would be a binding expression
binary expression is always start as a
from the column
we can say it's binding operator and
right after
the binding operator we write a
javascript expression
that evaluates every time when we
one of the properties inside that
binding expression will change
so the binding expression could contains
like a simple mathematic calculations or
it could call that
separate functions or you can write the
conditions by using a 10 or
10r operator or you can use a write a
huge lambda and
make a lot of conditions and structure
your code
a bit better you can also call the
functions
and then in that case your property is
going to depends wherever you use
inside that function
[Music]
so let's take a look how to change the
property by in runtime
so in that particular example we have a
rectangle which has a white
200 and his height depends on the white
is by multiple by 2.
if we want to change the property
binding there is a two ways
first of all is simple assign operator
it destroys
a property by and assign a constant
value so in case where the
keys on space pressed when we press
press and space
the height is going to assign white
multiple by three
and it will never change again if we
want to create a new property binding
then we need to use
a function called cube binding and
that's creating new binding and
allow us to to continue height will be
depends on the byte
but we just create a new one
let's take a look what else we can do
with qml properties
every qml property provide us a signal
it's when you define the property it's
implicitly create
a changed signal for you then later in
your program you either can subscribe on
that signal or
you can use the mechanism of signal
slots in the
c plus plus to connect to that signal
or do something basically the signal
always contains the same name it's
it's the name of the property plus a
change keyword
that is one of them useful features in
qml properties because
you don't really want always just assign
something and but you always need to
somehow communicate and understand that
your property changed then you want to
do something
that's one of the way how you do that in
qml
there is one more feature of the
qml properties it's called alias so
if we take a look at this particular
example we have a
component called my text inside of this
my text there is a rectangle and text
and later we use the my text a bit later
and we bind the text property to the
input
of the root property so in that case
we propagate the text from the my text
to the actual label inside of that my
text
that's kind of useful it's allow you
don't write the
setter or getter functions as we do in c
plus plus
just to say oh i want to use that
property and that property is the alice
to that property
yeah before we go to the summary of the
qml property feature because that was
almost
all important features of qml we need to
take a look one more thing
is when we actually evaluate our
bindings expression
because that's kind of magic we don't
really understand how it works
so i wrote a simple example and that
example there is p1
and p2 two boolean variables uh
properties
uh p2 depends on p1 so wherever p1
changes p2 should be updated
and there is a callback called component
on completed this is a basically a
callback which is always called after
the constructor
if we in terms of c plus plus so
wherever the item created the company
complete should be called and then we
can
start to work with our item so in that
particular
case if i run the program first what i
would i see i would see the
the debug output as evaluated by an
expression that means that
the binding is actually created during
the
construction of the item and only when
it's ready
we will we can use it so in our case it
would be p
one false p two false then when we
change the
say p one true it immediately will
re-evaluate the binding for p2
and assign a new value to the p2 in that
case we will see that the p1 becomes
true and p2 becomes true as well
that's kind of an important thing in
terms of
how the qml works and what you can do
with that
because some of you can look at the
example and think we actually don't use
the p1 and p2 for anything
we don't change any white height color
or something
but the steel qml engine is going to
relate this property bindings
and the reason is for that because
cumulative actually doesn't know what
you're going to do in your
lambda or where we want in your binding
expression
you're actually able to assign new white
or hide inside and then will you will
trigger the
the system should be updated so that's
why they always initialize them
all property banners in the beginning
because they don't know what you're
going to do inside
and just to make sure that everything
works
yeah there is a
second feature it's called i call it
partial evolution evolution i didn't
find the official name for that but
let's take a look at the example
here we have a four properties
name location remote and event an event
depends
inside in his his lambda on remote name
and location so if remote is true
then we get name plus online if remote
is fall then we get
name plus location
so if we run the
if we run that program we will see that
first of all we
the event will contain synthetic town
kensburg if we say remote true
and that automatically will trigger
revelation of the event
and it will print the next time it will
print online
when we assign location change the
location from kensburg to oslo
that actually doesn't trigger anything
because your property binding
is not anymore depends on the location
because even though the application was
changed
the removal is still true and in your
binding
expression you are not going to go to
the line return name plus
location so in that case
it's kind of a partial relation of your
property binary
so then if we assign the name then we
will get the
the event will trigger uh the binding
expression is
dirty we are going to relate it again
and then we will get them
a new event
that's a very important part of the qml
and uh
and it's it will be also important part
and simplest plus because
you need to understand when you write a
huge projects
you are going to have a lot of
properties and one property might
trigger
millions of other properties to relate
their value even though
they don't use it even though they don't
change any colors white height
they don't make any visual changes
so that's very important to understand
because otherwise you can
end up with the change in ones the thing
can change
rest of the world even you don't see it
that it will take your cpu time
so let's go to the small summary of the
binding qml property binding so it's a
simple syntax
it's very nice and readable it supports
change then property binding in run time
it support partial evaluation
it's a great implicit value change
signal
it's also support analysis so that's
kind of
common qml property minus features
let's see how we can do the same in c
plus plus
so that's the part about the sequence
plus please be ready if you have any
questions about that
part i assume that you can just write it
immediately and i will try to respond
because
the first part is kind of tricky
and if you don't understand the first
part it may be hard to understand the
next one
so please if you have any questions
write it i will try to respond
immediately
yeah good then let's take a look at this
this is a simple c plus plus property
binding examples
it's the same as we used to have before
in qml so we have two properties one is
the p1 the second one is p2
p2 depends on p1 and if we run the
program
we will see first of all p2 is false
when we change the p1 the p2 becomes
true
that's kind of a magic and the example
is perfectly valid you
if you copy paste it and run it it will
work so few things
we can notice first of all it doesn't
depends on the q core application hugo
application
or any queue application he doesn't we
don't use any
signal slots we don't use the event loop
so it's completely
separated implementation it doesn't
you're able to run your code without the
queue itself just basically copy paste
a few headers and it's almost going to
work
yeah so let's
compare to that with the qml what we
have in qml and what we had in c plus
plus
so as you see the syntax is pretty
similar
except that in c plus plus we need to
call qt make property binding
we need to call p1 value p2 value set
value
but actually there is no any technical
limitations
in terms of c plus plus so first of all
remove cube you make property binding
it's it's kind of it doesn't support it
right now but i'm quite sure it's would
be one of the interesting features to
request i think
instead of writing the q make proper
dividing just
assign lambda the second one we don't
really need to call any
p2 value or p2 p1 value
it's basically there is implicit
constructor which will
returns the value so we can eliminate
this as well
and the same for the set value we don't
really need it
we can just uh eliminate it as well i
didn't eliminate the p1 value
because currently there there is no
technical
limitation to remove the p1 value but
but it does it just doesn't support it
but
we can assume that it will be at some
day or somebody will push a patch
yeah so the same we can do for p1 set
value we can remove it
and just assign it true so if if we now
compare
what we got in uh qml and c
it's almost the same the difference only
is that
in c plus plus we we capture everything
in lambda by reference
and in qml we don't do anything it's
automatically captured by q male engine
there is advantages and disadvantages of
that syntax in qml
so first of all for example if the item
doesn't contain p1 then
then the cumulation traitor will find in
the parent and the parent and the parent
of that item and
go up until it will not find anything in
c plus plus it's more
straightforward you it's it's c plus
plus you set what you want to capture
then you get it inside your lambda
so it's kind of
i think easier in c plus plus but uh
let's take a look a bit deeper in the
simplest plus example
and see how the binding relation works
in that case
because that's a bit different that we
have in qml so i took the same example
as we had before i just added a bit more
debug information
and let's run the program and see what
we will get
in the qml the first line as our output
we get was evaluation binary expression
in the c plus bus we actually don't get
anything we get the p1 false
so we created the binding but the
binding was not evolated
when we call p2 value we actually
see that there is evaluated by the
expression
and then we get the value
so it's kind of a bit it looks like the
evaluation of the
property bindings in the c plus plus is
kind of lazy way we don't do it unless
we want it
so let's just check our theory that when
we change the
when we say p1 said fellow true in qml
we also
saw that the validation binding
expression was immediately printed
and that's okay that case in c plus plus
it doesn't happen again
so p one true and only when we
we call p two value then we will
evaluate the binding expression and then
we will print the true
that's a one of the main difference
between the
c plus plus version and qml version in
qml version as i said
when one property triggers his change it
can end up to trigger other millions
properties depends on your project and
how you wrote it
and c plus plus actually nothing is
going to happen unless
somebody wants to read that property
that's kind of lazy evaluation called in
simplest way yeah uh
let's take a look that example a bit
deeper and go step by step and actually
understand what's going on here
because it still looks like kind of
magic how the p1 and p2 knows about each
other what is that connection we don't
see anything in a source
code so
let's take a look what the qt make
property binding does
it's constructed property binding from a
lambda
it's assigned it to the property
and it's also when we first time create
the binary and assign it to the property
it's marked as dirty because nobody
never evaluated binding we don't know
what's the result of that binding so but
we don't call the lambda to check it
because we don't need it nobody didn't
ask it
for that so the next step
when we copy to value the property
inside check
is there a property binding is that
there is there is a property binding as
it's dirty then we actually need to
the the property um
binding so in that case inside the p2
value
uh the the p2
kind of marks that i started in the
global variable it marks
well i started the evaluation of of
of my property binding and then we call
the lambda
when we get to the lambda and when we
call p-value we know that there is a
global state somewhere said
well p1 or p2 is going to let his
binding
that's why how p1 actually can check
if somebody started evolution process if
that then
probably either i i will understand that
this property in the global variable is
actually
i'm going to be the source for that
property so the
the the p2 and stores that
it depends on p1 and the p1 store that
it depends on p2
opposite yeah yeah when we call the pset
value true
we update the value in p1 and we check
if somebody depends on p1
and we know that it depends on p2
it requires to p2 so then we
mark that binding as dirty and the next
time when p2 is going to
evaluate the binding
next time when we call the p2 value then
um it's going to check if the property
binding is dirty and then repeat the
step as previous one
evaluate the bindings mark that it
started the process and everything
so that's how it works if we expand this
p-value function just
in it's in a bit of the i would say
save the code but it's kind of a real c
plus plus i quite
kind of simplified the version what is
in the queue
but it's just easier to understand so if
you take a look at the
p2 value what it does wherever we call
the p-value it's
it checks is there is a binding is the
binding is dirty
clear observers so we want to destroy
because we don't know what
what we are going to depend on next time
when we call evaluation
so we mark in the global static thread
local global variable
that's well current binding
is that one we have we started
correlation of
p2 then we call the lambda when we call
the lambda
and we call the p1 value the same we
check
is there is a binding is thereby dirty
in our case the p1 doesn't depends on
anything so it's actually go to the next
step
you check is there a current binding
well yes it is
then we create an observer we mark that
this observer observe the property
this and that terms it would be p2 or p1
and that's how p2 knows that it depends
on p1
at the same time we save that observer
inside the p1 that pll knows that it's
actually it's a source for the p 2
variable
so that's basically how it works there
is no any magic it's a pure c
plus plus there is no no no no
involvement of metal object compiler or
any other
cute macro stuff so it's a
it's a valid c plus plus c plus 11
actually
uh code so
just the question is anybody understand
how it works or
it's hard to understand how it works
because if if you didn't understand i
can try to explain again
that that part
you feel free and mute and ask if it's
hard to type in the
in the room
so i would i would i would accept it as
everybody understand how it works
so as i said that's basically
very very simple way of implementing
this i'm not sure why it wasn't
implemented
many years before maybe because we
didn't have a thread local in the
standard but
but it was from c plus 11. so anyway
it's a cool feature actually
so let's take a look how we implement
the partial binding evaluation in the c
plus plus
i took the same example just rewrote it
from the qml to the c plus plus so again
we have a
four properties two of them name and
location
second or third one is a remote and then
we have an event which depends on all of
them
at the same and again there is the same
condition if the remote is true
then we use on the name and idle and
line
if it's false then we use the name and
location
so let's just go the same way as step by
step and see what's actually
going on so the same qt make property
bindings create the property of bindings
from the binding expression
at case lambda when we call first time
event
event value would trigger first
evaluation of the binding expression
because the binding was marked as dirty
the next step when we
when we try to read the lambda we check
if remote is false
then they haven't even depends on remote
name and location like
in terms of property bindings it depends
on three properties
and we call the uh not dot value but
it's the residential operator for
convert
them from the property to wherever they
are
so in that case we know that
evan proper depends only on three
properties right now because
well access only three properties
when we say remote true and we know that
the remote property knows that it
it is a source for the event property
we we mark the binding as dirty one
the next time when we call event value
we tried to eliminate the lambda and
before we started to relate them there
as we saw in the previous source code we
kind of clear the observers
so we don't really know what is who is
and what depends on
in that case so we started from
beginning
from the scratch in that case so
when we call lambda again and remote is
true
then we we construct the string only by
using the name
that means that location was never
called and location never registered
himself
as an observer so
that means if we change the location it
will not mark the
the binding as dirty because location
actually doesn't know that it's involved
in something
and the next time when we print the
binding is not dirty we just
read the cache value wherever it was in
our case it's in the seat account online
so um the next time if we change the
name for example
we know that the name knows that it is a
source for the event
and when we read the
when we try to read the value again then
we see that the binding is dirty
and then we try to revelate the binding
expression
so kind of very simple way
to do it by the way maybe some of you
guessed how does a partial binding
evaluation and the binary relation works
in the
qml actually it works the same way they
don't
as far as i know they don't check error
introspect the
ice t3 of the javascript or anything
they just
do basically the same way
so let's go next let's see how the cube
property provides the
signals in terms as we had an
ql so basically you're going to have
uh two functions one is there on value
changed
this the callback which you posted on
value changed will be called wherever
the value changed
and the subscribe is kind of the same
but only that you call the
the lambda when we just pass it so it's
immediately called the lambda which you
passed so we feel like
you want to subscribe and you want to do
something with the current value
if we compare to the qml property signal
syntax well it's kind of the same the
one thing is
there that in qml if you want to
subscribe multiple times on the
same signal handler of signal you need
to use the special type qml connections
in c plus password you are allowed to
subscribe
as many times as you want the only one
difference
in that case that you see there is after
signal handler after signal handler 2
subscribe handler
so these objects they're like a guards
they keep the lifetime of the
wherever you subscribe or you want to
call your callback
when this object dies you will never
call your
callback lambda again
so that's a bit different between the
qml and c
plus plus also important note that
it's in the current implementation of
properties
you're not able to pass or use the same
syntax
as you do in a signal slots you can you
can basically say
on value p1 on value change i want to
subscribe on
that object and call that slot that's
currently is not allowed
it's not like there is some technical
limitation it just
have not been done so probably i think
somebody will implement this
yeah so if we take a look how we change
the property binding in run time
in the c plus plus there is a few
functions you you can take a binding
which will just uh disassociate
the binding expression from the property
the binding is still kind of valid
and if we mark the we've changed the
location to say oslo
that the binding will be marked as the
dirty one but it just
doesn't trigger the revelation on
anything because there is nobody there
is no one property who use that property
binding
then we can always assign it back by
calling set binding
to set a new binding and if we
explicitly say that set the value for
the event then
the binding destroys it's kind of
similar what we had in
we have in qml so if we just compare the
examples
we'll see that syntax is pretty similar
the same unless that in qml actually if
you want to create a new binding
or like restore the previous one you
always need to create a new one there is
no way how to keep the binding in
in the qml so that's that's the
difference
if we look in the property analysis
so it's pretty similar as we
have in qml and cuba have a special
keyword alice
in the c plus plus we have a special
property alias
class basically let's just take the
reference pointer
to the property so in that particular
example as we
have in in the qml we have a my text
which insect encapsulate the text but to
provide them
his property on to the public api so
then you're able to subscribe or you can
change the binding or you set the value
or
wherever you want yeah
so if we take a look in the
summary of the features of the pq
property
then we will see that it still keep the
simple syntax
it support partial elevation it's
support analysis it provides signals
which is not kind of signals but just
the callbacks but still fine
it supports change property binary run
time
the extra feature is lazy related to
compared to the qml
and uh there are a few also aspects that
it doesn't depend on cure and loop it
doesn't depend on q core
gui or q application so you basically
you can use it in your
project even though you don't use the qt
itself
it's it will perfectly file work with
your custom types
you didn't really need to do anything
what it doesn't do is doesn't provide
the simple integration with signal slots
so there is no way for now quite i'm
sure it will
it's it only supports only single
threats so you're not allowed to
make a binding from the properties which
is leaving separate threats
i i don't know was it made like this
intentional or
is it just because nobody didn't think
about it but i know that the
c plus plus fully library open source
library from facebook
they implemented the same thing but they
allowed to
use the properties from the different
threads in one property bindings so
should be fine i don't think that cute
is going to do that but
maybe they will
okay the next step is what i propose is
take a look
what's actually happened what's going to
happen with the queue itself because
that's kind of a new api and we curious
how it's going to be integrated inside
the cube
because we as the developers who use the
queue then we kind of might be affected
because the cute sixes is not going to
keep the promise of don't break the api
or api capability of switching from the
q5
so the api might change but
it doesn't have to it might
so the current status in the dev branch
contains two approaches one of them is
it
provided in uq private property macro
it's already merged in dev and the all
changes in queue
kind of done it's not change any other
current classes but you can use it if
you want
and there is a new way how to do that it
was proposed
kind of recently by lars it's a new
keyword to the q property statement it's
called bindable
and we will take a look both of them and
compare what one is better
what ends worse and how does it work in
general
because from as i said from developer's
point of view i would like if the q6
will kind of keep the abi and api
capability that i don't need to change
all my source code just to to get that
feature
yeah so let's take a look from the first
one option one
so let's take an example of the simple
class in q5
let's take a look at the queue object
key object
has a cube property the statement which
defined there is one
property object name
let's provide two functions to read and
write object name and set object name
and it's also has a signal object name
changed
so pretty simple example
we already get used to the cute i would
say
magic with the macros and it's used by
met object compiler to generate meta
type information
and the that's basically it so let's
take a look what's going to
what kind can be happened in cute sick
it's not decided yet but
they're they're still ongoing
conversation but let's take a look
so in q6
on the right side and q5 on the left
side
we can see there is slightly difference
between what we
had and what is going to have or can
have
yeah i just highlight the changes we see
that in the private object we change the
q
string to bq property and
in the public class we see that the q
property is gone
there is a q private property this kind
of unreally understandable syntax what
do we pass there
nobody can guess unless you go and see
we also
don't see any more object name and set
object name
functions we don't have a signal as well
and there is some kind of weird three
microscope
properties begin property implementation
and end
so let's take a look what they do by
expanding one macro by
by one so
yeah before we expand the macro just a
few
explanations the q pro q private
pro q property macro first of all it's a
mock talking when the meta object
compiler
reads the header he will find that he
will understand well
that is my property i need to register
that in the meta type information
the second purpose is that provide the
wrapper for queue property or
hide the implementation of the queue
property from the
the end user to keep the api we will
talk a bit about that a bit later
but in general let's expand the q
private property and see what
what does it do so
if we expand the queue private property
we will see
there is a structure this kind of weird
naming cute
underscore queue underscore property
underscore api underscore object
that structure actually replicates the
queue property api
that structure doesn't contains any
members it's basically the size of that
structure is
should be zero but it will be only one
because on
c plus plus you cannot have a structure
which is zero
at least one so and also we see that
there is kind of
set object name so it's also
provide that by that macro
so let's expand the the three last
macros and see what does it do
so if we expand the macro we will see
that actually it's a union
we see it a declare
we see a declaration of our object name
and is that structure some of you might
ask
why is the union and why it's like that
the answer is very simple the cube
doesn't want to
they don't want to grow in size of their
objects or their classes
so basically since the cute property api
object name
structures is size of one
and the rest of them all other
properties would be also size of one and
well they can
share the same kind of
other space since they don't contain any
members and everything
so just they don't want that every time
when you
create a new property you will get extra
eight bytes for the
pointer to that property
yeah but
as we see that this uh um
this macro q private property
it's gives us a structure but it doesn't
give it's only declare the function
inside it doesn't provide the definition
of the function
so if we go inside and take a look
what's actually
mock generate for us that is his job to
provide some extra
helper functions for us we will see
what's going on
so that's how
mock object.cpp could look like
so it will generate the set object name
for us the body of that function
it's very simple just get the
pointer to the private class take the
property and say set value
pretty fine if it then we also see that
it generates the
api or the body of the body functions
for the
that weird structure i would say
so if you take a look inside what's
actually mock generates for that
q property api object name structure
will
find a quite surprisingly interesting
thing
so let's take a look at one of them
so the object name function
yeah so there are just three lines
first of them is trying to calculate
offset from the object name
in the it's it's trying to create the
offset of that
of the property which we define in the
union
the the to the key object itself
by doing and the second line is kind of
try to calculate that
this pointer of the queue object itself
not that this point of that structure
but this
the point of the queue object so
basically since the
q property api object name structure
doesn't have any
doesn't contain any members it doesn't
actually know where's the queue property
or the
deep private d pointer of the queue
object
exists so it basically calculates it on
the in runtime
all the time actually yeah it's kind of
tricky that it kind of works there are
just few problems
uh first of all
the static cost of queue timer to the
null pointer
like now pointer static has to the queue
timer and then they get the
others of the object name is undefined
behavior
but that works in the qt qml
it's in production since release 2010
there is a class called static cast
selector something like that and it's do
exactly the same
it works so the cute claims that
well on all modern
platforms that works so
we can trust them we can don't trust
them that's how it is
the solution was proposed in the mail is
to replace this calculation by using
offset macro
which is standardized and provided by
the standard library
but offset though doesn't support
non-standard layout so in that case when
you try to use offset in that particular
case it will
it will you will get a compiler error
you of course you're able to ignore it
you can disable that error but still
that's that's what you will get
and as i said even though if you use dev
set off and it's
not supported it still works okay on all
the
modern compilers you don't need to do
anything else it's just work just
disable the warning and it will
calculate
but standard doesn't guarantee anything
it's kind of undefined behavior
as well yeah
so if we take a look in the
second yeah so since we calculate the
property member offset by using
undefined the hero the calculator now
this this
pointer is also kind of undefined we you
can
you cannot rely that it's it's correct
so
but as i said it will it works fine all
modern compilers so you shouldn't worry
about that and it's
10 years in production it's
that's what we use nowadays yeah
so let's compare the what the changes of
the api of the queue object
will become when we will switch to that
approach for example
so on the q5 if we create the object we
had the three functions
we can get the object name we can set
the new object name and we could call it
signal
object name changed or when you set the
when you call set object name that
signal will be immediately
sent when you the the name is new
on the qt6 sites q6 side you you
actually
will get the object name uh
you can get the set object name then you
can object dot
object name set buying when you provide
the binding you can subscribe on the
value you can
just just make a subscription you can
set a new value
and optionally can be supported the
signal and
object name i didn't show it in the
previous example because
when i tried to implement the support of
the signal
that the example grows it becomes very
very ugly to see in a slide
so just just believe me that's possible
to do but the source code
doesn't looks very nice
let's go to the second option what we
can do with another proposal which was
made recently it's still under
discussion
but again we go back to the key object
in q5
so we have in private class we have a q
string object name the q property macro
and we have two functions object name
and set object name and we have object
name changed as a signal
so in q06
what we are going to have is the second
approach is that
basically the changes is happening only
in the
almost only in the private class
you need to use q object compa property
macro
which will do some magic for you
and then inside the public class you
just need to use bindable keyword to say
that oh there
you actually your properties support
bindings and you need to say which
function gives you that binding i'll
like
give you support so you see there is a
new function called
bindable object name that's kind of a
syntax
which is uh
cute is is kind of enforcing you
wherever you want to create a bindable
function then you need to call bindable
and then the name
so so what do we get with the second
approach we have a new keyword bindable
for the q property
we have a new api function bindable
object name
in that case we don't get the q property
but we get the cube bindable because
this is the same purpose
the qt wants to keep promise of the abi
and api capability so they just return
your eq bindable which is
basically repeats all api of the queue
property but just high that you actually
get the cube property
that they they can change it later some
internals or the queue property
or something yeah you will get three
different macros
it's called q object compact property
it's for capability with the old one
code if you use that then the source
code
works the same way as it used to be you
don't really need to change
anything unless adding a new function
then the second
macro is a computed property it's for
the read only properties
it will not store any cash value inside
the property binding
or the property it will always calculate
it on the fly
may be good maybe not question yeah
and there is q object bindable property
this is the
meant to be used for the new code and
yeah the question which macrocute is
going to use in their classes
is also questionable because in q6 they
allow to break the api
they can remove the functions they
that's also fine but i hope they will
not going to do that because otherwise
we need to
i don't know what we need to do to adapt
our source code to
to that yeah
[Music]
let's take a look just how the bindable
object name
function looks like inside so it's a
pretty simple
just get the pointer to the d uh to the
private class and just say
object name and basically everything
down that's what you need to do
with the option two with the option one
you need to completely change your
class or how it looks like on the public
so if you compare what do we get in if
we compare q5 and q6 and option two what
do we get we will see that
basically you get the same api you get
the object name you get the set object
name you get the signal
and you get the new function where you
allow to call
set the binding subscript and value
change
set the value or get the value wherever
you want
yeah so if we compare option one versus
option two in my opinion
the first one is looks easier
but you just get your object name you
don't need to type
or call a function or the name of the
function's object name bindables kind of
i don't know looks ugly for me but then
you kind of
my lost you can lose the
the previous api which you had before
so in terms of keeping avi and api
capability the second option is
much better because it doesn't break the
api it doesn't break the api
capabilities so you it's allow you to
use a switch from q5 q26 without any
changes
then the the news the new way the new
feature is available for you
you still need to change your source
code a bit because wherever you call set
object name
just as you used to have it used to do
it then you will destroy the binding if
you create the binding so you need
to change your code but still is like it
doesn't break anything
but allow you to experiment with the new
feature
so when do we get the cube property
it's currently available in dev branch
doesn't work everything i had to modify
the source code of the meta object
compiler
i had to modify some internals of uq
property to make it work perfectly
but basically it's there it's going to
be arrived at the qt6.0
it was planned for the december but
actually i'm not sure that it will be in
december
because of the well the
skew property discussion is still
ongoing and and nobody understand when
it's going to end
so i don't know when it will be
but i hope soon and as i said the
integration
how to integrate your property inside
cute is still ongoing discussion
should we break the api should we break
the abi capability or should we just
keep it as it is
but if if we don't break the abi and api
capability in q6 then
the next time we can do it we can do it
in q7
so it could be in the next 13 years
so that's the question what the cute
company is going to decide in that
in that case yeah
so some useful links
the original inspiration of this cube
property stuff is actually based on the
the article on the voboc.com it's a
block
of the meta object compiler container
olivier olivier coffee if i spell it
correctly
he wrote it in 2013 and he described how
it can be done
and later in after seven years we kind
of get it
so it's cool and there is api design
principle in the cute wiki
when and how you supposed to use queue
property it doesn't actually say how
the you should use it in the user code
or what to do is that
that's probably we should figure out how
to do that
and there is a good mail thread
in the developer mail list where a lot
of
conversation was happening about what it
is and how does it work
and basically you need to study the
source code there is no
currently a lot of documentation
so if you want you you need to
go and read the source code it's kind of
messy right now
it's going to be better at least i say
that the lars pushes the patches to
clean up the source
code because the first time when i saw
like what is that it's hard to read it's
hard to understand what it's doing
but it's it's with his patches it
becomes much much better
yeah so we will see
so thank you all for the
hearing me if you have any questions
please and mute yourself and ask a
question